a little shrimp ah
okay rethink that move son
i hate him anna's face garbage why don't
you just tell him to stop shaving at his
desk he denies even doing it i don't
know why
next time i catch him shaving i'm gonna
punch him so hard in the mouth he bites
his own heart
could that be why he denies doing it
oh yeah you could be right yeah
i don't like loud noises and people
making a fuss and i especially don't
like people celebrating because they
know a piece of private information
about me
plus the whole thing is a scam birthdays
were invented by hallmark to sell cards
i know you don't like anyone wishing you
a happy birthday so
crappy day to you still too much
i assume you're not doing anything to
celebrate tonight anyone over the age of
six celebrating a birthday should go to
hell come on everybody let's hustle
let's get to the brainstorming
great attitude ron
i just want to get the work over as soon
as possible so i can do some fishing
fishing relaxes me
it's like yoga
except i still get to kill something
i can disable the security dvrs but i
need some way of getting to a station
unnoticed i have an idea on how to
smuggle you in but it'll be a tight fit
i'm flexible i do a lot of yoga you do
yoga helps keep me centered if you ask
me about it again i'll hunt you down and
rip your face off okay great good plan
one time i don't escape this story is
awesome indeed
thank you for sharing jenny
ann was getting a little chummy
when people get too chummy with me
i like to call them by the wrong name to
let them know i don't really care about
them that's a genius move thank you
you're welcome lester
morning oh
i can't believe you live nearby and you
won't let anyone crash at your place you
people already know too much about me i
know exactly three facts about you and
one of them is that you won't let any of
us crash at your place i am only here
because i owe leslie a thousand favors
i'm not big on charities
give a man a fish and you feed him for a
day
don't teach a man to fish and you feed
yourself
he's a grown man fishing's not that hard
what the hell were you thinking you're
lucky you just dislocated your knee how
do you know it's located i went to med
school for three years you did when let
me take you there and you can talk to
the salesperson counteroffer you take me
nowhere and i talk to no one counter
counteroffer you come with me or i make
you attend a four-hour fax cover sheet
protocol meeting either way it's a win
for me
why are you being such a gloomy guest
i'm a realistic randy didn't go with
rosa huh i'm gonna have to meet a whole
new group of people i hate people life
sucks nothing good ever happens
morning dwight
who are you
who am i i'm jim we've been working
together for 12 years
we're joked white
you're not jim jim's not asian
you seriously never noticed hey hats off
to you for not seeing race
all right then jim uh why don't you tell
me about that sale that you made
yesterday
uh wellington systems sold them 10 cases
of 24-pound letter stock or were you
talking about creek or murphy because i
didn't close that one yet but i'm hoping
i've got a voicemail from paul krieger
waiting for me
please enter your password
you have one new method how did you no
no no no that is sensitive information
only for employees not outsiders dwight
cut it out i'm trying to work you don't
work here you're not jim jim i got us
that dinner reservation greek goes 7 30.
oh great can't wait
jim's at the dentist this morning and
steve is an actor friend of ours i don't
know who you are
but you are not jim
this is jim
oh dude oh how did
i have a great idea for a prank before
holt comes in i'm gonna put ink on the
podium where he puts his hands i don't
think he'll fall for that i did how i
haven't even opened this yet i guess
it's unrelated captain holt hates pranks
this is gonna backfire man ugh fine i'll
tone it down i'll
move his podium a foot to the left what
he'll be so angry okay five inches five
three three one one all right i'll move
it a half inch fine it's your funeral oh
my god
worst prank ever some stupid hult's not
even gonna notice
good morning
you guys are
the podiums
you're crazy how did you pull this off
i want to be your assistant
really
you hate it here so do you
i'll make sure you don't have to go to
any meetings
if anyone comes to see you
i'll scare them away
wait april if you had to choose between
these two ties
you're hired
i just figured i might as well get paid
for being here
ten months ago she was an intern who
could give a crap about local government
now
she's our newest employee to april
cheerios yay jerry come and celebrate
no thanks well everybody let's get back
to work
where are you going
i want to talk to ron about the size of
my desk
jerry
you have to schedule an appointment
okay how about now ron's not here he's
right there i can see him
i'll let you know when he's available
and a girl
detectives i see we got eight recruits
for the junior police program
outstanding thank you sir
but as important as your praise is to me
it should actually go to gina she's the
one that got through to the kids yes i
am amazing and i only asked for one
thing in repayment
a 600 raise or i could give you a zero
percent raise and make you my personal
assistant which is what i'm doing i
think you have hidden talents which will
make you surprisingly good at the job no
i have no talents you start monday
constantly getting hult's approval is
the worst yes i can only imagine
aristotle was plato's student and
aristotle believes that your character
is voluntary because it's just the
result of your actions which are under
your control
for example right now you have made the
insane choice to ignore the person who
is literally trying to save you from
eternal damnation no yeah yeah i'm
listening uh i just
are we sure we should be paying
attention to these guys it's like who
died and left aristotle in charge of
ethics
plato
um coming um we're just kissing
astronomy is full of interesting facts
for instance here's one that hollywood
doesn't want you to know
a parsec is actually a measure of
distance
one of the many inaccuracies in the star
wars universe
and was star wars
oh boy
maybe i'm getting ahead of myself okay
let's talk planets jupiter is a gas
giant so is hitchcock how does this help
me it also has 67 moons i came up with a
fun mnemonic device to remember them all
it goes every individual gets crayons
after telling his aggressive little
mongoose painter called ernest some lies
about
tiny panda heads period
maybe one kid could take her elephant
into california except
where's gina she told me you called me a
gas giant well now you and i will never
hook up
you